hi I'm JC from Maryland and I just want
to know now that we found water on the
moon how student you think we'll be able
to set up a moon base yjc yes we did
find water on the moon we don't know
whether there's enough of it to be
useful to us but it's definitely there
so how long would it take for us to set
up a moon base well it took us seven
years for the United States giving top
priority to getting the Apollo program
to to go and seven years from start to
first landing on the moon that was a
tremendous national effort that took
everything the United States had to
offer half a million people worked on
that project so in seven years with a
half a million people you could do it if
you don't want to put that much work
into it it'll take you longer so maybe
10 15 20 years depending on how much
resources would be made available
technically we could do it quickly